[Musique]
d
or après toiles et nids qui sont bonnes
jamais correspondu aux attentes aux
stéréotypes de ce qu'on attendrait de
quelqu'un qui a signé puis je me suis
jamais j'aime pas non plus le désir de
transition pour devenir un homme non
plus je me sens bien quelque part entre
pour moi la découverte secousse a été la
découverte de moi même et puis de foc
foc foc sauf tant pis pour les l'écart
trop stricte je veux je vois être qui je
suis pour rien et et partir deux mois
pas de l'extérieur
[Musique]
sortie
samuel est une jeune artiste qui prend
son envol après avoir décroché le grand
prix au dernier festival international
de la chanson de granby
elle est la fille de gaston mandeville
musicien chanteur compositeur qui a été
emporté par le cancer il ya 20 ans
samuel n'avait alors que 11
[Musique]
toute une socialisation est basée sur le
fait que deux genres distincts et
complémentaires fait quand quelqu'un
arrive puis dit ouais non moi je me sens
pas bien là dedans mais ça rend
généralement les gens très très mal à
l'aise l'identité c'est quelque chose
qui est complexe parce qu'il est
multiple c'est plein de choses que je
peux je me lève pas le matin la fin des
jeunes écrire puis mes chansons sont pas
nécessairement courir le monde
personne au monde à découvrir dans mon
entourage professionnel qui sait pas un
problème en se déclarant publiquement
queer samuel contribuer à faire
connaître cette réalité mondiaux guitare
acoustique et contrebasse mesdames et
messieurs on entend court toujours en
direct des studios de chez eux avec
manuel mais pour moi il ya deux choses
mon identité puis comment les gens
perçoivent ces deux choses qui sont
distinctes pour être capable de vivre
sage il lâché prise sur la façon dont
les gens me perçoivent
alors oui lesbiens trans et arme anti
10,6 fait
enfin sexuelle un fluide demi sexuelle
je me couche à sexuelle
les universitaires tente de comprendre
et d'expliquer les revendications des
personnes queer
c'est un terme parapluie qui englobe
toutes les identités qui se veulent
d'une part contestataires et qui se
veulent aussi fluide et changeante
ouverte à de nouvelles définitions
ouverte à une évolution dans le temps
qui n'exclut pas personne
[Musique]
le chanteur veillette débit fixe bourges
ont permis son doctorat en psychologie
clinique
il s'intéresse aux thérapies sexuelle
moi je suis attiré par les femmes mais
j'ai droit aussi cgem ses pouvoirs ont
le droit d'être moi même d'exprimer les
instruments identiques correspondent pas
aux normes strictes de l'armh unités il
ne se réclame pas du mouvement queer
même si l'on adopte certains codes
j'ai beaucoup de privilèges de temps et
un hétérosexuel et un homme et en blanc
c'est j'ai pas été marginalisés ou j'ai
pas vécu des préjudices comme comme
d'autres groupes fax pour ça je fais
attention à peu prendre des identités
politiques qui m'appartiennent pas ses
copines lara est très ouverte aux
artistes courir dont on ait trouvé les
oeuvres dans sa boutique du divin saint
laurent sa douzième qu'elle vient
d'ouvrir
cette diversité est de plus en plus
visible pourquoi les réseaux sociaux
favorisent l'expression individuelle et
envahissent la vie privée du furieux
émoussé selon les chercheurs
l'adolescence se prolonge le jeune va
être dans une période peut-être 10 ou 15
heures au cours de laquelle il va vivre
des relations amoureuses des relations
sexuelles qui ne seront pas encore
définitif si on veut et qui peuvent
suivre plusieurs modèles autour des bots
you gênant et la maman de simone et aude
du temps et deux ans c'est elle qui
vient chercher les petites à la garderie
tout près de leur ferme familiale à
brownsburg à la frontière ontarienne les
mondiaux pékin tube baby et l'autre
maman des fillettes et l'a 40 ans et est
originaire de chicago depuis très jeune
je savais que j'étais bisexuelle que
j'étais attiré par tout le monde que je
que le genre est importé pas dans mes
attirances dans mes préférences
sexuelles
quant à jenna et la 33 ans et viennent
de l'alberta suis identifiée comme une
fille troutman lesbiens bisexuels et
trans queer j'aime pas quand le monde
matt les messieurs
toutes deux sont au québec depuis le
début de leurs études universitaires et
bi détient une maîtrise en géographie et
jenna les docteurs en biologie
samuel m se réfugie ici parmi ses amis
loin des bruits de la ville ici à la
ferme les champs qui chantent aux
produits des paniers bio qu'on vend à la
ville à toutes les semaines
alors hébreu on cultive aussi une grande
ouverture quant aux orientations
sexuelles et aux identités de genre
c'est moi personnellement ça a été
je voulais plus vivre avec les choses
changent
faites tout ce processus là d'avoir bien
comment comment je peux faire pour être
bien
c'est un processus qui est difficile
mais qui est important puis en vrai que
j'ai plus envie d'être avec des gens qui
ont passé par là aussi cessé de crier en
place siph
c'est beaucoup si tu étais le parlement
qui est un défi pas comme une escale au
rabais stéphanie aussi denis autour de
la table chacun a son parcours celui de
jenna et est si unique
dès l'âge de 4 ans elle se sentait mal
dans sa peau elle n'acceptait pas son
corps de garçon
avant j'étais vraiment sa chair est
toujours contente quand et be a
rencontré jenna il ya sept ans celle ci
lui a tout de suite dévoilé son secret
le plus intime
elle m'avait dit je suis en transition
il faut que tu sois d'accord avec ça 1
puis je dis ok depuis sa transition
milieu de la vingtaine
jenna ne craint plus le regard des
autres sa transition est le résultat de
traitements hormonaux intensifs et de
chirurgie radicale mais avant elle avait
prévu avoir des enfants
c'était notre première rencontre qu'elle
m'avait dit ben là c'est sûr que c'est
très important pour moi d'avoir des
enfants à m'amener puis je pense comme
congé mais mon sperme puis gésir ou ok
pour parce que pour moi j'ai jamais
jamais imaginé
donner naissance à eau mes propres
enfants
finalement ça tombait que j'étais la
seule avec une utérus donc c'était à moi
de les porter max mosley toit commun
comment toi de sam six mois est-ce que
ça comme une fille ou un garçon ou ni
l'heure ni l'autre je sais pas toi de
toi tu peux décider plus tard vous
sentez heureuse oui ouais c'est sûr mais
je lui pardonne dans ma vie comme tout
le monde mais relativement qu'avant de
transition c'est vraiment plus facile
ma vie c'est comme je suis contente j'ai
une stabilité extraordinaire avec tanner
je sais qu'elle est toujours là pour moi
puis dont convient
petit travaille fort pour trouver ton à
voix haute en place depuis quand le
trouve et te trouver ta lumière une fois
que tu es dans ta lumière depuis besoin
de confronter les gens ont hâte d'être
dans l'agressivité c'est plus un besoin
[Applaudissements]